how scum Reza's b'doop b'doop
ah welcome back to work I am so tired I
could say anything a t-rex [ __ ] ate
our last time so hopefully we can find
our buddy
what that [ __ ] is going on there ha ha
oh my god
uh yeah you pay some [ __ ] [ __ ] punch
and that's or you can punch them
unconscious ha ha ha
it's tamable eye let's kill it
what are these light things I never
explored them oh my god how much do I
[ __ ]
let's take it throw it
catch this [ __ ] yeah we need to get all
our stuff back uh which is probably
gonna take a while but that's okay I'm
having fun
okay I'm starving I'm out of water
I should [ __ ] constantly I lost all my
items I'm tired
I would Oh Mike I love all up yeah oh
love it so much
what's makes herself a pair of prada
boots my [ __ ] mom Prada boots the
[ __ ] is this little piece of [ __ ] can I
kill this oh I have no choice
oh that [ __ ] [ __ ] poisoned me I'm a
furry hell about that aww
I'm died okay I died here remember that
funny hell of it might yeah what do you
do in a little while I'm so sexy oh I
love it
miss me daddy I'll fist you all I want
push that meat out of that [ __ ] this is
for vegetarians punch that [ __ ] is
that we hold in Sweden we punch them in
the pooper
what are you looking at I'll punch all
the poopers this reminds me of where I
die this is where I huh oh my god this
is yes okay nice that's that's a little
nice maybe we can find our first body I
wondered that stupid where did I die the
first time I was like along the shore
somewhere and this [ __ ] [ __ ] just
ate my face off a footnote I'm not gonna
[ __ ] you
just run pills run for your life
we did it like a rolling yeah there's
the [ __ ] [ __ ] Rick's that kill me oh
my god does that mean our body is near
oh man I want to kill it so bad
vengeance yeah come back here
scrub oak 9:10 a.m. damn damn damn aah
mom dude t-rexes can't swim hurry
aah aah
hi there little fella you have a [ __ ]
man before well you have now this is
where we died the second time oh my god
what the [ __ ] where are we oh my god
there's the Bell oh my god are you
[ __ ] kidding stop no no no way no I
have that
oh hey Tim it's so me
it just picks on the week such a dick
move that dinosaur is gonna die if it's
the last thing I'll ever do lever do
Oh No is he [ __ ] camping by my corpse
got a lot of [ __ ] done this episode
looking for my dead bodies while I keep
dying yeah yeah it's your time to die I
just [ __ ] myself
why are you all god oh my god just
[ __ ] die
last shot oh I'm good at all that's what
I'm talking about
Oh God I'm doing that thing again no no
no no no no oh god I need stones ah you
know what I changed my mind let's just
go for what we came for the dinosaurs
has so can we can technically tame this
one I wonder what we get more like XP
from my child what the [ __ ] [ __ ] Paul
that dinosaur is gonna die if it's the
last thing I'll ever do dad what the
[ __ ] what happened